please welcome Kirsten Dunst and Tobey
Maguire
a young girl's fantasy inspired by a
very real war a dysfunctional family
pulled together by a common goal a time
vending rumination on today's global
village and a pair of real-life tragic
events these were the stories that
inspired the original screenplays we
honor tonight
Guillermo Arriaga for babel irish
Yamashita and paul haggis for letters
from iwo jima michael arndt
for Little Miss Sunshine Guillermo del
Toro for Pan's Labyrinth Peter Morgan
for the Queen
and the Oscar goes to michael arndt for
little miss sunshine
in order to write Little Miss Sunshine
Michael Arndt had to quit his job as an
assistant to Matthew Broderick
thank you very much right you'll have to
forgive me my voice is really shot a
writer is only as good as the people
that he works with so I have to share
this with bill Weinstein and Tom
Strickler who read this cover when no
one else wanted to read it my producers
Albert Ron Mark David Peter and Jeb who
made this movie when no one else wanted
to make it with Greg Kinnear xx Collette
Steve Carell Paul Dano Alan Arkin and
Abigail Breslin who collectively saved
my life and especially with Jonathan
Dayton and Valerie Faris the true
authors of this movie who took words on
a page and turned them into a work of
art and finally when I was a kid my
family drove 600 miles and a VW bus with
a broken clutch so it ended up being the
funnest things we did together so to my
brothers Jan Dave and Chris my mom who's
here tonight and to my dad who's with us
in spirit this is for you thank you
backstage at the Oscars were holding
pieces of paper in front of our camera
but it's alright because it's a thank
you cam
speaking of pieces of paper after 18
categories how's your Oscar ballot you
filled out last week looking chances are
it's got more scratches on it than a
lotto card given all the surprises but
surprising results in categories like
costume design and Best Foreign Film are
just an example of the strength of these
categories Pan's Labyrinth by the way
already has two Oscars lots more still
to come including Dreamgirls going for
its third Oscar of the night in Best
Original Song it's got three to choose
from so it might not do so badly and
that Best Original Screenplay award goes
up against three of its Best Picture
competitors for Lowe in the sunshine is
that a sign of things to come
stick around and find out there's so
much more still to watch as the semi
ninth annual Academy Awards continues
who gets to go home with one of these